hello everyone I'm Alana ochar a lot of
zodwa today we are going to talk about
cholesterol particle uh I played this
game when it came out and finished it I
think just around Christmas and it was
certainly not what I was hoping it would
be which is a dead space clone
effectively I feel like that's what most
people expected especially being that
some of the team had worked on Dead
Space and I do want to say nothing but
love to that team
um who effectively got laid off from
visceral and then watched EA remake Dead
Space anyway and obviously the Callisto
protocol was made uh with a much smaller
team and a much smaller budget then
would have been the case if they were
still in EA that whole situation really
sucked but it was not what I was excited
for I ended up thinking it was kind of
okay I had an okay time I finished the
game
um in a way that I think I played it a
bit more like it felt like a sort of
Gears of War than it did like a dead
space but I'm not here to talk about uh
any of the things that I disliked about
it across the board
what I wanted to talk about and I was
waiting until the Dead Space remake came
out to do this so that I could like
properly reflect on it is why this game
isn't scary it's a really interesting
one because it certainly has a lot of
the correct DNA of something that should
be scary
um starting with some of the best faces
and best facial capture I've seen in any
video game this game graphically is so
incredibly impressive uh the lighting
the Shadows the sound design are all
things that you would think should be
scary so it's extra surprising that it
just doesn't work there are moments
where the music swells and things are
tense and yet I never had a fear in the
world so I just kind of wanted to talk
about for example something like this
why it didn't scare me the combat is
certainly the biggest proponent of that
I think but I think there are also um
some extra facets to it that I wanted to
get into first because it's a really
easy one to get through and because we
just saw it is jump scares this game
relies on jump scares and often the
exact same jump scare um and in a way
that even that is disappointing I feel
like the most effective jump scares are
there to alleviate tension so tension
really has to ramp I felt no tension in
that scene that we had just watched in
the jail cell it was it was clearly he
was sort of drugged there was something
wrong with his vision a very small space
quite dark um but there was no tension
and I think that that is consistent
across pretty much the entire game if
there is no tension there's no payoff
for a jump scare there's no ending for
the tension so the jump scares don't
really work plus most of the jump scares
in this game are really just something
large and Loud filling the screen in
fact all of them are where I tend to
feel like a more effective jump scare is
like if you see something in a
background just standing there or you
catch something out the corner of your
eye that you didn't expect again in a
moment of tension with which this game
just absolutely does not have so the
second thing that I think uh prevents it
from being scary is the level design and
that's pretty obvious from the jump
right here um we're walking down a
hallway and that is effectively the
level design in the entirety of Callisto
protocol with an absent of two parts
that um I actually loved both of those
parts there's one that's sort of like an
outdoor snowy area where a bunch of the
enemies are frozen and you don't know if
they're gonna attack you or not and some
of them do but it's very cool the other
was an underground sort of old city that
um while it also didn't end up being
very scary was one of my favorite parts
of the game in terms of actually having
something to explore but majority of the
time it is what you're seeing right now
which is a hallway that leads to another
hallway that leads to another hallway
and that goes exactly in line with the
story as well I feel like it's a staple
of survival horror that you are often
seeing the same environments repeated in
environments that you are slowly
unlocking and you are tracking things in
your head right you are getting invested
in that environment by saying there's a
lock door here that I need to unlock
where there's a possible here then I
need to find something for so you have a
personal objective that ties you to that
environment that makes you remember that
environment and fear the things in the
path in front of you this game doesn't
have any of that kind of thing it is a
constant series of walking down
different or new hallways there is
occasionally a fork that will lead you
to a path that has some Collectibles or
something but for the most part it is
just constantly going forward and the
story is perfectly in line with that
which to be fair I kind of respect the
story is ultimately
um a person who has very few Stakes uh
your whole Emma really is to get out of
the prison and survive that's that's the
whole thing you don't have anyone you're
looking for you don't have anything you
really care about and it's guys like
this guy for a very long time and a
couple of other NPCs who are basically
just overcomes telling you to keep
moving forward I think that kind of
removes your agency from exploration
which I think also some of the tension
from that exploration also uh yeah this
game has unskippable cutscenes and no
chance to select unfortunately so I had
to start from the start which I imagine
is slightly more cutscene heavy so with
minimal Stakes other than get out slash
survive
um just hallways that often look very
very similar which I think is okay Dead
Space has a lot of similar looking
hallways too and characters in your ear
just constantly telling you to keep
moving you don't feel like you really
have much of a part in the story so all
it actually ends up becoming is a series
of combat encounters there is no
decision making for you to hesitate on
the path forward is always very clear it
is always very obvious where you need to
go and it becomes pretty obvious pretty
quickly what's going to be on the other
side and I think that that works as an
action game in a Sci-Fi setting in fact
this does work as an action game in a
Sci-Fi setting there are some decisions
that are kind of um a little bit
annoying like the heel mechanic takes
too long and a lot of the enemies can
jump on you uh if there are too many at
once and it makes it very very difficult
um this game well again I did like
things about it by the end it does have
one of my least favorite levels in
probably any video game ever which if
you played it was the tram
um my gosh that took me I don't know
hours and not for my own fault so again
we're seeing another hallway and someone
has told us to go somewhere in which
case we will find more hallways and I
think part of the issue with the
constant like go forward Motif which
makes perfect sense it's really clear to
players where they're going and what
they're doing at all times like it is
very very clear what you're doing no
attention and decision making but also
our protagonist never seems to be afraid
at any point he never shows any
hesitation he doesn't even really seem
to care very much about anything he's
certainly just very frustrated but he
never reacts to anything in fear
including combat which we're just about
to get into for the first time here and
the combat again is ultimately in my
opinion the biggest problem with this
game that again is otherwise beautiful
and creepy looking and very well
designed in a series of ways that would
allude to fear a la sound design and um
and visuals so combat in this game
at first I found extremely confusing and
then once I figured it out I found it I
would say just way too easy
you have to just dodge left and right
and it doesn't matter what direction I I
the first time I thought it was
confusing because I thought that you
would have to Dodge in the direction you
were being punched from but it's not
that it's just left and then right just
whatever Direction you dodge the first
time you have to dodge away the second
time and I will say I think some of the
gore stuff is actually really fun there
are some very long death animations
unfortunately again
they aren't skippable but some of it's
like very over the top and Goofy and it
was pretty fun to watch in a kind of
Mortal Kombat way in my opinion so here
we have our first um enemy which
what he just did kind of scary but when
I can just do that and then that
that's it the whole thing that
Dodge left Dodge right okay
he's a little East Dodge left
okay
Dodge left and I can just hold left by
the way to dodge it just keep moving
left doesn't matter where I go and then
right no it's not gonna hit me again he
actually did get a hit on me that
because I waited too long but that's
basically the whole thing the whole time
just move left move right okay and that
is again essentially what I think is the
biggest problem with this game is that I
ended up having absolutely no fear of
the combat whatsoever there is some
Resource Management that would almost
make it matter where you can
occasionally like run out of ammo and
and you'll have to reconfigure in your
inventory but the one thing that you use
most of the time is like a baton a melee
weapon that never runs out that you have
to use all the time so if every combat
encounter is left right hit left right
hit which for majority of the time they
are the only variation later in the game
is an enemy that spits at you and then
it does get to a certain point in the
game where um certain enemies will like
grow tendrils out of their chests
basically
um actually that happens to virtually
every enemy so even that doesn't have
much tension into it I expected it to be
some but it makes you prioritize who you
hit and what timing you hit them and you
basically have to shoot the tendrils in
the chest before you melee them but
because of that whole system the way
that it works with limited uh concerns
even about being hit some of the
checkpoints are far apart but for the
most part it's fine and you just dodge
left right hit and you get your health
and you fill it up there's just also no
tension in combat in fact as I am
walking through this game the combat is
the thing that I'm doing it for I am
trying to walk towards things that I'm
going to kill so in Dead Space where
you're terrified that something is going
to kill you very quickly or you're
terrified of the way the enemies move
then jumping out of a dark place jumping
on you because you need to keep them as
far away from you as possible the
Kalisto protocol does the opposite and I
get doing the opposite in terms of
making sure it's not exactly like dead
space the issue is that the reason Dead
Space did that was clearly to make sure
that there is tension in the combat
where this again right now if I can hear
something I want to go okay where is it
and how do I get towards it not where is
it and how do I make sure I keep it away
from me I am immediately like all right
let me get towards you as fast as I
possibly can
Dodge Dodge
and
that again as scary as they might sound
or as creepy as they might look or get
later in the game
just means that there is no fear or
again that word tension in doing this
whatsoever the combat is definitely the
biggest problem and by the end of the
game I didn't again I didn't mind doing
the combat I just saw it a lot more as
something that was action orientated
than as something that was supposed to
be scary which I don't think is the
intent there is another one here
somewhere where is it
can hear you but I can't see you and I
said there's not a lot of enemy variety
there are robots which can kill you as
soon as they see you and we'll kill you
as soon as they see you but they are
very very easy to stealth around and
also the consequences for death just
aren't that extreme and there are some
things in the game that like are creepy
like that's pretty creepy there's uh
this one section that has this oh no
series actually of traps there are
things that are creepy and things that
look creepy but again it ends up being
more like an action adventure with
creepy sci-fi elements than anything um
that is actually horrific again I'm just
going to walk towards you I'm gonna go
left I'm gonna go right it's gonna hit
you
three times
left and I think that's basically the
core of it
um it's that we have a very linear game
which again linear is okay there are
places for linear games I often like
Linea games but linear in every sense
that it takes any decision making out of
things
um there are also effectively no Puzzles
there are things that are akin to
puzzles but it's very very that's a very
loose definition of puzzles it's really
just some navigation trickiness
occasionally um it's pretty uncommon and
even that means you don't actually have
any decision making so it's a very easy
game to play without really having a
sense of investment
um or again with that a sense of tension
again that's kind of a cool thing in a
Sci-Fi Action game but it doesn't make
me afraid of it again this is it's
creepy in theory
um this someone's Whispering my name uh
it just doesn't end up
really having any consequential payoff
for a player I think it it's basically
an accumulation of things the the combat
and the linearity and the narrative all
tied together that just make it a really
really passive experience and I think
that in order for something to be scary
you have to have investment and decision
making and you have to care about the
characters even it's not to say that all
of the writing in any Resident Evil game
is necessarily good we've certainly had
some blunders there but they at least
have characters that we end up really
caring about which I don't feel is the
case for any of our characters here
especially our protagonists who
basically doesn't exist and Dead Space
was similar to that obviously Isaac used
to not even talk uh and that was okay
but at least I understood that he was
extremely underpowered and if I were
Isaac Clarke opening this door
because there's no tension in the scene
I don't care the jump scares are the
hardest thing for me to explain it's
really odd I think the times that I
jumped the most in this game is when a
hologram appeared and I didn't expect it
to for some reason I don't know I just
kind of wanted to talk about this um
about why I think there's an
accumulation of things that make this
more of a Sci-Fi Adventure than a horror
game but I would love to hear if anybody
strongly disagrees with me if you found
this game super scary again I'm not
saying I found it bad I'm just saying I
didn't find it scary because those are
two very different conversations I would
love to hear uh what you found scary
about it because as a scatty cat this
hallway to me is just another hallway in
this game that makes me go I hope I get
to fight something do you think there's
any loot rather than um any immediate
threat immediate tension immediate
consequence despite it being a stunning
looking video game with very very good
voice acting performances and
um again some of the best facial capture
some of the best lighting that I think
I've ever seen in any game really ever
it's just definitely an issue with when
you can predict how almost every
encounter is going to go or what's going
to be behind almost every door attention
is never really there unfortunately